hi there steve kaufman i want to do a
review of pimsleur
i bought pimsleur because i have to go
to romania on business in early june
just for three days i'll be
on business in bukovina and then touring
a bit
in transylvania
and
we've also launched
romanian at link
but we haven't got all our resources
organized yet we just put the
dictionaries up today there's nothing in
the library
so i said i need to get started because
in six weeks i'm going to be in romania
so i phoned around and the only thing i
could get with sound was pimsleur
so i went and bought pimsleur
uh i i also do have
at home a copy of teach yourself
romanian which i've never studied but i
have no soundtrack for it so i wanted to
hear what the language sounds like so i
went and bought pimsleur and so i
figured i would do a review of pimpster
uh pimster is quite popular with many
learners
uh so you know i thought i would
see what what the uh what it's like i
have looked at pimpster before i have
pimpster at home in fact
for
portuguese and for russian
but in both cases i was already fairly
well along in the language
having used resources like teach
yourself or link and so i found the um
pimsleur russian or pimpster portuguese
simply too boring so i it it wasn't a
good test of pimpster because pimpster
is always
uh you know recommended as a good
beginner
uh
you know system so here i am a total
beginner i know nothing in in romanian
so a good thing a good place to test bim
store so my first reaction to pimsleur
is that it's extremely
well done the quality of the recording
is excellent the voices are excellent
uh it's very easy
in some ways it's quite it's quite
comfortable it's not demanding
um and they repeat stuff over and over
and over again basically they have
simple words and phrases simple phrases
which are then broken down into words or
smaller phrases
uh you're told what it means in english
you are prompted to ask someone
something using the words and phrases
that you have just learned
and it's extremely repetitive
so
each of the 10 cds here's one cd there's
10 of them in all
30 minutes each typically they will
cover
no sorry there's five cds and each seat
each lesson is i think 30 minutes long
i'm not entirely sure
um i should say that
uh since buying them i bought them on
wednesday today is friday
i've listened through just about all the
10 lessons there's a little bit in the
last lesson i haven't listened to
i listened mostly in my car i also
imported them into itunes and downloaded
them onto my ipod nano so that i could
listen while exercising
and while doing the dishes so basically
i've found the time to listen to
most of the lessons
um
you have the impression that each lesson
begins with a
very short dialogue two or three
sentences
uh and then those are broken up and
jumbled in different forms of it do you
wanna have lunch do you wanna have lunch
now do you wanna have lunch later do you
wanna have a drink do you wanna have a
drink at my place do you wanna drink at
your place do you wanna have a drink i
want to have a drink and just goes on
and on and on
uh so that
it's possible that these phrases because
now i've heard them you know over the
last
three days however much time that i've
spent however many hours that amounts to
these phrases just come back and back
and back
will they stick with me i don't know
it gives you a very painless
introduction to some of the
idiosyncrasies of the language but
there's a limit to what you can cover
and and in fact
pimsleur covers very very little i'm not
the first person to comment on this
there is very little vocabulary there
um
i think in the first lesson which cost
me 27
uh basically what we've covered is do
you understand romanian do you
understand english yes no
uh do you want to have a drink do you
want to have dinner with me at my
apartment or in a restaurant
where is plo pilar boulevard where is
eminescu street
you know and and and
they go to great lengths to help you
with the pronunciation even for things
like plopilar boulevard
plopilar lar lilar plopilar
you know and locular boulevard is not
something that i consider all that
useful
so uh and there's you know there's a lot
of effort to make it simple like aichi
is
is here
este
is is here
and then they'll say notice that the
words kind of run onto each other este
which they don't really do any more than
most words where there are two vowels in
any language will tend to run on a
little bit and they must mention that
three or four times so there's a lot of
superfluous
advice and and english and so forth so
to my mind
uh i i want to see
the advantage is that i've had a
painless introduction to romanian
and probably having listened to all that
romanian because the other the other
source that i'm going to go at together
with link is this teach yourself whoops
let's get it on the right side of me
well that's not very good there we go
and i mean just in reading the first
three four lessons of teach yourself
i have covered more vocabulary than is
covered in the whole of pimsleur
so if i were to continue with pinster i
mean i would have to spend an awful lot
of time listening
and
that's the other point in pipster why is
there no
transcript i can't understand why they
wouldn't provide a transcript
maybe it's because it would become too
obvious to people
that there is very little uh vocabulary
there but if i hear you know
intelligent into what it is
i can't really make out the sound
because i'm not used to listening to
romanian if i could read it
and i kind of looked at how these uh you
know how the romanian you know spelling
works
i'd have a much better chance of
remembering it remembering the
vocabulary and remembering the
pronunciation at least the way the way i
learned so
to my mind it's a bit frustrating that
there is no there are no transcripts
also
pimpster is based on the idea that if
there's a space repetition it's going to
help you learn
um in the short term i'm not finding
that to be the case uh when they prompt
me to say something i'm not able to say
even something that's been repeated now
since the first lesson i still can't do
it i can't respond that quickly
you know i believe that it just takes
time for the brain to get used to a
language
and
i don't see the benefit in having this
spaced repetition
within this artificial and very boring
and uninteresting context
it seems to me it would be better to
get going with
more in with denser content
keeping it simple
where you are listening only to the
target language
but you're covering more and more
material so you are
in fact achieving this based repetition
because all of the most common words and
phrases are going to come up very often
in most contexts so that there's no need
you know it's more it's almost spaced
repetition if you're studying you know
vocabulary lists so pimster is almost
like a vocabulary list but if you have
meaningful contexts which pimster
doesn't provide
meaningful and interesting context you
know within a month or two
i mean this is the other thing about
romanian you can read the newspaper very
quickly because the difficult thing in
the romanian in romanian is the
day-to-day conversation in the newspaper
uh i downloaded some items
into into link from newspapers
you know the director of the bureau
announced that there will be an
investigation into the situation all the
words they use are words that we're used
to from english so that the it's not
difficult i think to get into
more advanced material in romanian
pretty quickly once you figure out the
if and then by because and some of the
phrase forms which are
non-intuitive but but my repetitive
listening to pimsleur hasn't made them
any more intuitive they're still a bit
of a black box for me if i were able to
read them
uh
read them in different contexts i think
would be more more meaningful to me
so uh i don't want to be too negative on
on pimsleur here i sound negative i'm
telling you exactly how i react i react
the way i react because of the way i
like to study i like to study from
meaningful context i like to read
as well as listen i need them both
pimster doesn't provide that i'm not
convinced that this artificial space
repetition within that system
is effective
but it is pleasing it is easy
i'm sure that that the
large amount of english that's in there
is comforting to most learners
who are not
so keen to get totally thrown into the
target language
uh if you're in a hurry to learn the
language
um i don't think hempster is the way to
go uh as an icebreaker uh i think it's
it's good it's easy uh and and uh you
know this is the part that i have
trouble measuring when i go back to
reading and i will also do a review of
of the teacher's help book uh
reading the teach yourself book before i
did pimsleur which i did
and then having done a bunch of pimsleur
listening when i go to read in the teach
yourself again it's more alive to me now
because i've heard it in action now
is that because i was hearing it is it
because of pimsleur if i had had
the cd
that goes with future self would i have
had the same
you know pick up through listening
uh when i go back to reading i don't
know
so um you know a lot of these things are
hard to gauge i know that uh when i was
doing russian
a lot of material that i listened to
very very repetitively
those phrases stayed with me
for years they would be the easiest
phrases that i could call on
so there is an advantage in repetitive
listening uh however i don't understand
why they don't reinforce it with writing
and uh
you know as manfred spitzer said in his
book the brain requires repetition but
the brain also requires novelty
interest
and there's relatively little novelty in
pimpster it's
i think you could you could describe the
plot line in about you know four lines
in the whole
ten lessons of
instinct so there you have it i'm sure
i'll get criticized for being too harsh
and i'm sure that there are lots of
people whose learning style
makes pimpster ideal for them
for me i think it has been beneficial
there's hardly anything you do in
language learning that isn't beneficial
uh the question is would i buy more
pimsleur books or pimster cds for the
next you know to progress further in the
language
the answer is no uh would i buy a
pimsleur
uh cd if i were gonna take say start a
language like hungarian maybe in fact
probably that's what i would do i would
buy one pimsleur to break the ice
um i say that now without having heard
the audio for
the
teach yourself but i have ordered it and
so
the experiment with pimpster and other
systems continues thank you for
listening bye for now